- We the Legends of Chamberlain
Heights.
- You want a bad one to fondle
your balls?
- Then check out our
Top 9 Hoop Movie Lines.
- You trying to peep Basketball
Diaries,
and get up on this Leonardo
Di-mack-rio?
- I got Hoop Dreams of you
letting me hit that coffee with
my creams.
- Say mommy, Juwanna Mann to run
this
dick and roll with?
- You want to netflix and
chili with some Hoosiers
and taste some of my Jimmy
Chipwood?
- Hey, you trying to
milk it Above The Rim?
- You wannna scrimmage with my
Sixth Man?
- Say boo, you trying
to get your Space Jammed
and your face jammed?
- White Men Can't Jump
and they can't hump,
so why don't you let a real man
dunk a ball in your hoop, Billy
Hoe?
- You trying to swallow these
Blue Chips?
- Okay.
- Hold up, really?
- Hell no.
(hip hop outro music)